everything's fine nothing's different at
all
don't worry though and welcome back to
resident evil village
hey sorry for interrupting this lovely
resident evil video but i have an
important message to give you red and
link just released a new scripted
podcast called
ronstadt hey bronstead ronstadt john
bronstadt is a supernatural noir comedy
set in a world filled with magic
monsters and all things mythical you had
me at supernatural
like distractible this is a wood elf
productions that you can listen to on
spotify
apple podcast or whatever podcast
listening device you use here's a link
to the podcast and here's another one
and another one there's also links
conveniently in the description
if you don't feel like typing go check
out ronstadt right now
well not right now watch this video then
go
okay good uh i'm gonna go now we're
making our way through heisenberg's
factory we discovered that he has way
too many drill doh men
so he's got a bunch of these i'm
guessing zombies
because it's kind of the point of
resident evil that's pretty cool too
damn quite a fact i don't know why they
need a merry-go-round for all the drill
doh men
seems unnecessary but what do i know hey
did i buy everything that i needed to
buy from you
welcome yeah welcome whatever uh bubba
right you have other things that i can't
get an investment
i still don't know what the hell i'm
supposed to sell so
really i'm not sure what's an investment
and what isn't so i'm just going to
leave it at that for now
all right i'm going to go meet again
soon yeah i'm sure we will buddy
um there was something else that i
needed to go down for uh let me go back
real quick because there was another
door down there that required power
i remember it so if there's something
secret down there
then i will want to get that although
there are a lot of enemies around here
and it's been costing me a lot in terms
of bullets
i'm assuming they're gonna load me up
before the big boss but who knows
they don't like to do that all the time
also a little problem i moved to the
pantry because the acoustics are better
in here but also
um there's no airflow so if i suddenly
pass out
uh hit the like button really hard and
that'll alert the authorities that
i need help probably i don't know i
think it's supposed to work
i mean it must let somebody know
something otherwise why would the like
button be there
anyway the door was right yeah
what's behind here hello
hi anything
please do please don't be a spooky
surprise
well something it was going to be a fun
surprise oh
hi i have a ton of those flashbangs they
just don't know what to do with them
oh okay you know i did not want to go in
there the thing is um i really actually
didn't want to go in there at all
so joke's on you buddy i don't even need
to be here
it still says there's something still
says there's something here but
i don't know what it's not like i still
need to do anything
yeah i don't need to do anything i'm
gonna go out to the other place and then
i'll
probably be making progress and that guy
won't cause a problem for me
what was the shadow oh okay that's fine
be right back okay we're on this floor
where did we
come from to get to here we came down
that way so there's a ladder ah
okay hello you know i am doing a lot for
still missing some fingers
you think those would have grown back by
now by how much goo i put on my hand got
a long way to go
how do you know that just because the
place is cavernous and big
i mean the only thing i'm trying to do
is escape so i don't even know why i'm
still here
i could just go out in any moment but no
i gotta hang around
explore the whole junction talk to all
the drill demons
okay um could i just shoot him here and
then they all fall down and then i'm
very happy
is that yellow for a reason bang nope
well that's me wasting bullets again
like an idiot
miranda thinks we're nothing
okay
i don't give a [ __ ] about your family
drama yeah i don't i really do
i wish i was better at this
follow up huh two can play at that game
hey oh okay no
you [ __ ]
[Music]
all right what do we have here herbs
goop stuff like that
okay good for me bad for you all right
let's keep moving
what else is in these mines somebody
else want to say hello
i'm a friendly guy i'm a very friendly
guy
i gives my bullets generously
yeah i just want to get the thing off of
his head probably again
hey stop stopping the name of the law
eat these bullets
reloading reloading reloading
reloading what yeah
take some of this you gotta follow up
there not for me
you die okay thank you finally about
time
i love dancing with you guys but really
actually i don't love dancing with you
guys and i wish you guys would never
dance with me large crystal can i have
it thank you
large crystal can i have it thank you
what are these crystals for
anyway they keep digging them up there
must be some kind of a purpose
because all this is related to the mold
of some kind i don't even know what the
mold is i mean i know it was in resident
evil 7 but i don't know what the mold
actually is i don't know if it's like an
offshoot of the
original flower that caused all the
resident evil stuff to happen
i called the resident evil stuff you
know all those zombies and whatnot
but it all ties back to the umbrella
corporation somehow oh
i know what that is that's a good boom
hole
here's kaboom it bam
it's all these gems that for some reason
i'm never selling i don't know why but i
don't really wish i did
i just can't bring myself to sell stuff
i always think that it's gonna have a
use somewhere somehow
but it don't what is happening
oh yeah that's healthy for whatever that
is
oh i can see the purpose of this machine
oh yeah it's the
the the scrap tumbler it's the the
the jagged metal jumbler yeah i know
that is this still recording it better
be
okay yeah this is just healthy for this
to rain down on my head
i really love that thank you what kind
of engineer proposed this one
what engineer i'm gonna put a big fan
and i'm gonna make a bunch of metal rain
down on it
oh is it gonna miss the fan no it's
gonna hit it a lot
oh yeah definitely this is an engineer's
nightmare like moving parts are bad
enough but whatever the hell this is
supposed to be
another one another what oh hey okay all
right i didn't even know you
hey what's up yay
it was up do it again ram oh
hey hey listen buddy you deserve one of
these
have it it's free want another one there
you go
twozies boozies
clumsies man you guys are kind of tough
okay and there they go hell yeah hell
yeah hell yeah
oh hell yeah that was definitely worth
all of my pipe bombs
boy i wish i could get past this
obstacle it's impossible though
all right anyway yeah let's go back to
the nightmare fan
yeah seriously what kind of oil
lubrication does this machine need
maybe you'll need pieces of metal
getting broken up into it it somehow
creates lube
and drains it off of all the scrap yeah
that's what it does
it's protective definitely i imagine
they wanted me to fight those guys for a
lot longer because it seems like there's
a whole lot of nothing happening so
uh kind of just the tinkle tankle of
machinery dropping on my head
which is nice but uh i guess it would
have been a lot more dramatic when i was
fighting somebody
thank you for the money the money that i
probably won't be using
i've got to stop it somehow i've got to
stop this what do you mean i got to stop
it
oh the machine that was definitely going
to run for a long long time
i have to stop it bang nope
well that ain't it chief oh bang
what about that other machine that i
blasted how about that other one
happen to that one
somehow wow that broke it
four bullets as opposed to all the
cavalcade of different pieces of scrap
raining down on its head
i broke it my conniving mind
my mastermind this this deceitfulness
my incredible genius yeah i'll just
stand on this
all right it seems safe it's the stairs
it's perfect
what is this machine for what in the
world it's a rock tumbler but for metal
and not for tumbling all right whatever
i'm gonna stop making fun of it because
obviously this
what is that never mind i'm back to
making fun of it again what kind of
totem pole last thing is that supposed
to be
what do you what do you convince me this
is for
huh what purpose is this oh those are
the the
whirly flangers oh they make sure it
looks cool when it's spinning
great good great
all my engineering professors are
rolling in there well they're not dead
probably they're rolling in the
classroom right now just tumbling head
over heel
soledad enhancement project sold that
jet attached to jetpack
greatly improves mobility experiments
prove limited flight capabilities
no long distance flight but now possible
to navigate rugged terrain
great that's really good i'm happy about
that
it's really hot in here by the way
because now my laptop is gushing out the
frames and it's just like really getting
the
really blasting the frames up all over
me i didn't read all that so
that enhancement project attached
aluminum alloy shielding to a soledad to
protect chest reactor in exposed flesh
experimentation proves he is invincible
against regular firearms
armor doesn't hold up against strong
blasts further development needed
yeah isn't it tough enough how much more
do you need
how much more could you possibly need
how much grinder the grinder yell kit
the grinder shaft
okay the grinder shaft imma move this
i'ma f this hard there we go
oh that was good glad i did that
anything else here
hello who
who the hell
yeah maybe uh maybe maybe uh
i should have let myself get grooshed
if one bullet can cause all of that
destruction
this thing's really was just hanging on
by a thread
it was really nothing keeping this
together there was absolutely nothing
holding all this
no way look at this garbage come here
you wow
bruh there we go thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you for all of this goodie
all right do i am i stuck down here is
there going to be a big alligator coming
out
i thought there might have been
something else over there like the heidi
what about the hidey hole
am i not gonna be able to get back
though i thought oh i didn't know that
was a secret i thought that was the
official way
oh what the hell screw you i didn't know
that was only a one-way return
god damn it you suck god you suck
there's gonna be a secret hidey hole i
it's not like i'm trying to not do the
secret stop
yelling at me i know it's not my fault
it's it's fault it's really hot
i'm really hot
okay all right where are we now what are
we doing what are we doing
what am i gonna miss out on next
probably more craftables or sellables
that i was never actually gonna sell i
get it
this button can present are you really
going to have that and i have a button
all right up i go i guess soon she'll
start her
ceremony with your ruffles then why did
i get all the pieces back
it's all over for your kid wait
for the whole village wait stop hold on
don't worry
i'll stop it i'll use rose
to kill miranda wait hold on hold on
you're the only one who doesn't see your
kid's power
what do you mean i don't see her i'd
like to see you try
i'd like to see you try i would like to
see you try
oh key mold oh that's handy but also
why did i collect all the pieces and
kill them if i'm if i just gave them
to mother miranda can can you explain
that one to me
can you can you run that by me
didn't i get those hard one i killed
people for those
pieces of my daughter i murdered
things for those and then i just handed
them over some don't add up here
some don't seem right the same a little
weird
there's more yeah of course there's more
me and of course there's more the place
is freaking huge
this place is freaking enormous hey
what's up buddy what's up hey is this
the dude
the duke the dude duke
the duke dude man convenient for him
just to be able to ride
the elevator up everywhere boy sure
would have been lovely if i could have
done anything about all that
hey why is it taking me so long to get
up here hey
there he is there he is hey what's up
buddy what's up buddy what's up buddy
let me go
save real quick where's your safe
machine thank you
[Music]
all right can you explain something to
me naturally
how the hell did you get here and what
is any of this
what is going on man what is going on
because none of this makes sense
none of this makes sense maybe i should
do sell these i'm just gonna do it i'll
screw it i don't even care anymore i
don't even
care i don't even care anymore i
care so much about you i would never
hurt you ah there's nothing else to sell
um i could get this auto shotgun that'd
be pretty cool but i don't even know if
that's gonna be worth it with how many
shotgun bullets i get
what i really need is a better pistol
but my pistol's about as good as it's
gonna get
um i could get a different gun expand my
inventory
the thing is i don't know if this oh
machine pistol
oh i want that yeah
[Music]
yeah okay can you pick what you're going
to say before you get through it yeah i
guess we just switch over the
machine pistol i suppose all right you
know what i choose something i'm not
much for holding on to things i don't i
don't like to be sentimental about
nothing
i say as i keep crystal dimitris but
that's not sentimental that's like
that's a need so i'm just going to sell
this screw it get out of here
go away thank you no i'm not going to
uh i'm going to get rid of this whatever
the hell this is goodbye
goodbye goodbye
yeah whatever
all right that's good enough there oh
greatly reduces recoil i like the sound
of that
sure sure
yes i can see sure
sure i'll upgrade the firepower
oh yeah that's a potent weapon that's a
problem i'm skilled at all sorts of web
good
what did you say to me [ __ ] all right
machine pistol i still don't have
bullets i need bullets
oh i got a lot of scrap let's just let's
just load up on pistol bullets screw it
what do i even care anymore what do i
care about anything i'm sweating it's
hot
i'm warm i'm very very warm okay so i
need to go back down
i need to do the key mold which is on
the first floor which is actually before
and then maybe i'll go up to b3 and i'll
go through that little secret passageway
that i pushed out of the way
which i thought was the way to go
forward because it was so damn obvious
but alas i guess i'm just an idiot
don't answer that it wasn't even a
question okay good hello
hi how are you excuse me
why is it dark why would it be dark
why in the hell would it be dark
oh screw you don't get scary no you're
not supposed to be scary you're supposed
to be shooty shooty bang bang
all right i'm a brave brave boy
i'm brave i'm so bro
whoa hi bud okay what are you doing all
right well
that's you're not stopping you're
supposed to be stuck oh
my ribs boom
wow really hurt
okay well a little less scary a little
more just a whoo
but that's fine okay i'm just gonna
carry on my way and pretend like that
didn't happen you know i thought machine
pistol meant like
automatic or something it seems to still
just be single fire
no no no no oh hey bud
bam yes
okay well you're not so tough when you
just fall over dead
can i get this and get out of here i
really don't want to be here much longer
speed would be greatly appreciated thank
you about time
okay there was another door down here
that was key
over here let me get that before i go on
lovely weather we're having hi if i know
anything about
the secrets down here it's just going to
be a pathway to another enemy
that's going to kill me damn it's going
to kill me dead
oh look at you hey hi
glad i opened this one
uh-huh i'm not sure if this is more
powerful
seems a little more powerful
okay well i did that thank you for your
patronage
what do we have here oh a mechanical
part i have something about that i got
this this
bam okay complete
i am a weapon the hammer hammer weapon
weapon hammer heisenberg's hammer it's
too heavy
it's too heavy god damn you
what is the point of you what is the
point of tantalizing me with this i got
a freaking knife
i got a stabby stab you're gonna show me
a hammer oh hi pal
god damn you just
to hell with thee to hell with thee
fine whatever we're just gonna go on our
way and we're gonna pretend like
everything is totally fine
and it's not dark and it's not spooky
and there aren't demons lurking in the
darkness
hi who the hell do you think you are
you're oh my god what am i even looking
at what
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
hold on one second i need to uh do a
thing here
let's see uh okay cool all right come on
down
all right cool uh how about another all
right come on down
that's really cool uh here's another
oh how about one more
all right come this way come to papa oh
[ __ ] oh god you're still alive
bam oh man
bam whoa
man bam
there we go that's how you do it
oh perfect perfect you say
well if you were so perfect you wouldn't
be dead and i wouldn't be winning
so i guess i'm the perfect one now
aren't we aren't we
aren't aren't we it's not a question it
is a fact don't answer it you're dead
and don't you answer it you're sassy
oh oh another one well i got a recipe
for you that you're gonna love
watch this okay you were
were you watching okay okay were you
watching okay keep watching
keep cool keep keep looking bam
are you looking you're looking you
better keep looking
you dead
show me your smile okay well how about
your smile
okay well
okay
okay i'm kind of stuck here can we uh
agree to disagree or something
go you're really backing me into a
corner here buddy i don't have much
else besides the big kaboomer and i
really need to hit you right on your
target to do this
okay okay okay dodge
bam [ __ ] get done
get done in okay you also have a perfect
one but i'm gonna say that it's not
exactly perfect if uh
if you're dead i like i hate to be the
bearer of bad news but
it really is thusly and there couldn't
have been two
perfects because the other guy said he
had a perfect heart and in reality he's
kind of
perfectly dead but whatever hey buddy
you want some hearts
go ahead and go up and then i'm gonna
you can't talk while we go
oh stop oh stop bitching would you ever
just have a heart attack or something
what's wrong with you
you good you good bro bro
okay now you want to talk thank you no
actually i want to sell you something
perfect also my laptop fan is a gushing
it's really heating up man let me let me
let that go oh that's really warm
oh that's scalding hot that's probably
not good
it's it's very warm in here i'm gonna
open up the door for just a moment
because it's
very warm also i have an ice pack on i
wonder what would happen if i put the
ice back on the computer would that help
it or hurt it
okay we seem to have cooled down to a
reasonable level okay
i'm gonna sell these hearts and then i'm
going to buy
an upgrade to my p stool kaboom i know i
could get a better shotgun and i
probably should
because it seems like i mean that just
seems like it does better
but i don't feel oh that does way more
damage
i definitely should but i won't because
i'm an
idiot so now that we've got that covered
in out of the way we can move on with
our lives
ooh ammo capacity yeah yeah why not
move forward than anything
you're right my friend anything even
family
have a great day i'm going to carry on
to heisenberg and i'm going to show my
business and
the first
well that's a little overly dramatic
don't you think can't you
someone waiting for it
who could it be is it you
prototype sturm use the cheap turboprop
engine but he's impossible to control
all he does is charge too much power
output from the reactor
completely invincible head-on but the
dumbass managed to chop his own damn
arms off with the propeller
also issues with overheating from
running for two for long periods of time
conclusion a complete failure oh sturm
all right sturm okay overheating you say
so i just gotta run away from him is
that what i gotta do
his sturm is too dumb to be controlled
is that what it is cut his own damn arms
off like a
fool sturm stir me
western i don't have time for this
[ __ ]
out of my way oh oh okay sturm what do i
do
ow jesus what the hell sturm
sturm what the heck oh god oh god oh god
okay
all right sturm you got it buddy um
well i see i see what i got to do okay
come at me
well actually we'll need i don't know if
this is going to do anything just yet
come on come on come on
oh [ __ ] god damn it oh no
no no no no no
no
nice term man you're kind of dumb
boy howdy that i feel bad this
this is just sad come on sturm
stir me
where's the overheating i heard a lot
about this overheating
you'd think that the blades of that fan
would prop off by now but
apparently not
uh-huh uh-huh why don't you uh come over
here
wow i was not didn't realize you were
coming over here that quickly
we're heating up baby
okay you didn't tell me the heating up
meant flamethrower
that's different that's a different
thing
holy [ __ ] oh god he's
pissed he's bull he's pissed
come at me
okay this fire doesn't seem to go away
um it's kind of a problem
it's like when i played world of
warcraft i just got to kite him you know
kite the fire patterns and all that
oh my god
do i have an oh god
okay i'm not sure what causes him to get
oh boy oh it is the pipes okay so he
gets caught up in the pipes
that's what do it
i could knife him to death i could
oh he's mad
his boss fights kind of taking a bit
guys sorry
oh what the heck and hack
okay i'm just gonna wait for a good shot
and i'm gonna blam them
oh you're not dead yet
come on come on now stay down oh
that got him i probably wasted one more
bullet than i needed to but that's okay
whoa oh he's complex
not perfect you know it's the
imperfections that really make something
special and i think that's really echoed
in this game a lot ah
how nice okay whatever let me get out of
here that boss fight took a while
hey uh heisenberg what do you think of
that pretty impressed right pretty cool
yeah i like big dick energy if you know
what i'm talking about
oh okay
miranda is abominable her deceit knows
no bound
we're merely a bunch of failed cadu
experiments to her
i was just lucky i had more affinity to
the stuff than the other poor schmucks
in the village so she still calls me her
son
what a joke i'll never forgive her for
what she did to me
the crazy [ __ ] has never been right in
the head she can't see a difference
between experiment and family
miranda didn't just change my body she
took my dignity
if i don't kill her then my life will
never be my own
still she may be crazy but she's also
powerful she can turn anyone
using the mega my seat the trick is that
brat rose
if i could access her power then maybe
speaking of the
of the kid's dad ethan has a pretty
interesting body himself
maybe i could get him to help me out oh
so you like mine body is that what it is
oh heisenberg if only you had said
sooner or may perhaps we
could have shared time oh
hello no i'm actually looking at the
secrets here
oh okay hello
all right well i got that in here but
that's technically not everything else
where
says that there's still something in
this other area um
well i don't see anything
no oh here we go in the locker very
obvious
okay thank you eisenberg that was very
fun
i do appreciate that big preach huge
preach
everyone write preach in the comments
for how much we preach that
because we do all right i'm gonna climb
this tiny ladder
for whatever reason i do this oh
yeah okay yeah okay
oh yeah okay oh yeah
okay
i'm doing this now
i'm going up now this place is designed
a little funny
i'm not gonna lie it's almost like i
don't know a game designer put this
whole level together
it's almost like someone made this for
flow and function and
smooth transitions and cool visuals as
opposed to you know
a logical factory or someone with
magneto powers did it
i'm not sure which is true hello
hello anybody home anybody want to talk
to me
anyone want to hang out
okay yeah hmm
[Music]
not bad not bad jersey
you're a persistent but i've got a
rebellion
so stay out of my way
uh when did i get that gun
[Music]
i mean admittedly he really doesn't seem
to want to actually kill me
so that's pretty cool you know i'm not
gonna lie also am i gonna survive this
somehow i am
a giant underwater monster
man i'm tough as nails yeah that bastard
cool yeah it's fine don't worry about it
not being a [ __ ]
again yeah damn
it yeah what do you expect me to do down
here heisenberg what do you expect me to
do
just fall over and die i don't know if i
can
there's too much goo yeah where's my
wife mia where's she in all this
why can't she use her epic amazing
powers
i told you to leave it alone ethan
you are in the way what do you care
chris
you killed my wife you son of a [ __ ]
you think i killed mia
that wasn't her it was miranda
what she's a bio weapon
she changed her appearance and pretended
to be mia
seems she also survived being shot so
now i'm here to finish the job
[ __ ] why don't you [ __ ] tell me
right away
because i knew you would want to be
involved and this job is hard enough
without civilians getting in the way
why huss chris
what the hell is going on
all right ethan all right
i guess i owe you an explanation
hand me that wrench yeah what the hell
is this thing that you're building here
it looks pretty dope
oh am i gonna get the explanation do i
not get i don't get it do i i don't get
the
i don't get the explanation okay well
that was okay
long story short miranda's [ __ ]
insane oh
in this village all these monsters and
freaks
this is her life's work some sort of
crazy experiment with the mold
the mold like louisiana
god damn it all this time i thought i
could save my family
i can't escape from here i can't do
anything
that might not be true
take a look at this my men sent those
pictures a few minutes ago
miranda keep looking
rose holy [ __ ] we gotta go relax my men
are monitoring the situation
but they have my daughter you don't get
anything
you don't stand a chance against miranda
by yourself
i will stay down here and finish
planting explosives you take that
elevator
i'll meet you topside i promise you we
will get your daughter back
together damn straight will i when i
find miranda
she's a dead woman
all right ethan and you take this
and do me a favor try to stay under the
radar
you're gonna give me a tank with a
chainsaw on it and you're gonna tell me
to stay under the radar
you just blew up the elevator that you
told me to go on this is
so [ __ ] rad but also really [ __ ]
dumb
i had my baby i literally had her all
pieces of her
and uh well the only reason they have
her is because for some reason then i
didn't have her you know what i mean
i used kind of used her as a key to get
through to a place doesn't make a lot of
sense
because i had her i had her chris you
could have been like hey he's got her
we'll go get him out here we'll blow
nuke the place from orbit and you know
it kind of
anyway that's it for this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching hope
you're enjoying it so far i think we're
approaching the end
don't think we're gonna get there in the
next episode but soon we're gonna look
at this laptop and we're gonna have a
lot of fun so thank you
and as always and we'll see you in the
next video
bye-bye
[Music]